the Tennessee Titans are eventually
gonna have some decisions to make at the
quarterback position maybe not during
the season maybe maybe after the season
or most definitely at some point before
free agency in 2020 because Marcus
Mariota is in the last year of his
rookie deal and in the first half of
last night's game he did not look good
at all six of 16 at one point Ryan
Tannehill had his helmet on it prompted
reporters to ask coach Mike Vrabel after
the game how close was Tannehill to
being put into the game Vrabel said not
very he just simply was listening to the
play calls that way okay well I know
this when Marcus Mariota came out in the
third quarter and all of a sudden was
like a guy who'd been shocked into
consciousness I couldn't help but wonder
as he was driving the team down the
field on that drive that ultimately
ended in a fourth down play at the goal
line that didn't make it did he get some
sort of an indication in the locker room
that maybe he's got a problem maybe he's
got an issue maybe there's going to be a
benching in the offing if he doesn't
snap out of his funk and he did at least
for the third quarter I was very
concerned by the lack of urgency from
Marcus Mariota and the entire Tennessee
offense in the fourth quarter down 22 7
half of the quarter to go trying to
drive down the field too slow to the
line of scrimmage
too slow to get the ball snapped and you
know what if it's the others who are
lollygagging and not moving quickly
enough it's on Marcus Mariota to demand
that they do what they are expected to
do in those moments and get their ass to
the line of scrimmage and get ready and
get moving because they have to show a
greater sense of urgency when they're
down by two scores it's almost like they
were conceding and that's not good
enough and at some point if this
continues Ryan Tannehill is going to get
a chance to show what he can do because
they're gonna have to evaluate him and
what he brings to the table in making a
decision about 2020 once they get to the
point if they get to the point where
they begin to decide that maybe Marcus
Mariota is not the long-term answer
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports